what's up guys big shout out to helix
sleep take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life
find your perfect mattress at
helixsleep.com
griffin let's start the show okay let's
do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to your favorite podcast
this is
[Music]
just the boys come on yeah yeah
[Applause]
you hear the girls
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to ripping
with griffin and we're here and i got a
guest today i got the great
jamie kennedy coming on we're going to
talk about his new movie last call
we talk a lot about what's going on in
the world his fear of coping
some traveling that we did so
going to saudi arabia just a lot of
stuff and just it's good to catch up
with my buddy so
thanks for being here
[Music]
all right anyways like i say thanks for
being here again a roofing with griffin
got another uh guest episodes my dude
like i said jamie kennedy having talked
i've seen him once during the pandemic
we did an outdoor show
and uh now he's here on my uh uh
podcast so i hope you guys enjoy and you
know we'll watch
uh the trailer for his movie and
then we'll go so youtube people will see
the trailer
but people just listen on audio we we
won't
be skipping right to the interview
because
it's weird to play the trailer
i don't know maybe i'll you know what i
don't even know what i'm going to do yet
you know you know the in in editing who
knows what will happen but
anyways thanks for being here remember
once again that i uh stream every day on
twitch look out for me on air graphic
gaming on that
and i also have those sometimes i put a
bunch of videos up on youtube for eric
griffin gaming so just look for me here
griffin gaming on twitch and youtube
and here we go ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the podcast mr jamie
okay uh ladies and gentlemen here he is
my friend the myth the legend himself
um the scraggly right now uh
mr mr jamie
kennedy there he is there amazing
brilliant and funny
says his mom
[Laughter]
yo yo that's rough man that's fans in
town that's a local folks
no i just get it i know i love i love
all those those those are always the
best do you remember when you first
started and you would go like out of
town someplace and then like maybe
there'd be like a local write-up in like
the
the montana tribune or whatever thing it
is those just
i used to collect those and be like oh
man i'm in the paper
the oc weekly i was like oh
there was something something called the
beach reader the beach reader it was
down
like hermosa that was like the beach
paper and i got a little light up and i
was like
yeah you felt like i know you felt like
it was like this was
this was the the best thing in the world
so listen before we go even further
because i really want to delve into you
i love seeing you i mean i've only seen
you once in a year now
well we saw each other at that little
outdoor show but uh
you're in this new movie it's called
last call we just uh for the people that
are watching on youtube we just saw the
trailer
um so you know looks good man tell me
about
tell me about the movie what what what's
going on here with this uh
this new project you got going on uh
well
it's real close to my heart so the movie
takes place
in a fictional city called darby heights
and darby heights is uh based on the
the city that i grew up which was upper
darby
and upper darby is right outside of west
philadelphia so like where like the
fresh prince
comes from i'm coming from like right
outside that
and it's basically about a guy who you
know made a lot of money and he's got to
go back to his family to help
you know basically he gets this he gets
a bar and
he wants to help the town uh rejuvenate
and he's got to basically pick a choice
between
you know re making a a business decision
or helping his town and uh it's like a
feel-good
type of story of of of a guy who did
well
who's coming back and and you know
reconnecting with his roots and it's
it's all a lot of shot in my old
neighborhood and it was made by a guy
who i went to high school with oh wow
who made a lot of money
in the same way the main character did
and then he came back
and fixed up part of the town it's like
a real it's a real cool story
but it's just a real good like it's got
like a
if sundance was going on right now bro
we might be there
you and i oh you really slow you know
what i like how
i like how passionate you are about it
just when you say close
some people say this all the time this
is a project close to my heart but
i actually can uh knowing you i know
that this is like a this
you you you seem very proud of this
project
dude yeah you know i mean so you know
some movies some projects i paid for you
know
my pool with you know but this isn't one
of them you know i mean
this was like you know wait wait wait
just say mask
two money right here right
[Laughter]
wait wait wait this ain't you in front
of you being a computer tech in like
nine movies money
[Music]
yo enemy the state bay in the late 90s
if you needed a computer check
yeah yeah yeah yeah they were like he
just he's just cute enough to be the
computer attack
that's so cute he's gonna take away from
the lead yeah
he's not gonna he's not gonna get the
girl but he gonna he gonna do the [__]
out of that pascal
you know what i mean
he'll welcome you at the local fries i
got you man
it's a feel it's lit it's about my
neighborhood uh
and cherio terry i don't know if you
know this but she she went
to the the girl version of the high
school i went to so i went to all boys
she went to all girls and tina fey went
to the public school
oh wow i went to uh all boys high school
too i thought you know
you know that was an interesting
experience i know right but there's
something freeing about it because you
don't have to like try to impress girls
but then it's all dues yeah so but
anyways though so that's the last call
it's it's you
jeremy pivens taryn manning bruce dern
right yeah um kathy moriarty sherry jack
gallagher zach mcgowan
it's great man it's it's all andy is
coming out
march i believe march 19th we were
i think we're gonna be in select cities
we're gonna have vod
definitely amazon prime and uh you know
oh she's gonna be in those
you're gonna be in those we don't care
cities yeah
you know those cities that bleed red
yeah we're gonna be we're gonna be we
don't probably come out somewhere in
texas right somewhere yeah somewhere
easy you know what i mean well i just
went to arizona man and it was uh
it was um i was really i was really
nervous i mean let's talk about this
stuff now it's like
the last time i saw you again we were
doing that matt rife show the
the low-key outside show shout out to
them for keeping comedy going
especially yeah and when i saw you at
the time
i could tell that you had a healthy
paranoia about kovit
right is that is that a good is that a
fair description of how you uh
yo how healthy i was like a vegan of
paranoia
gluten-free paranoid yeah i could tell
that you had um
you know you had that you had to have
fear about it i mean you know
how was it you know when you were uh you
know
when this when it's all broke out and
like when you decided to finally venture
out i mean how was that for you um
well like dude i say i quote you uh
it's one of the funniest things is they
say you're like look man
eventually we're gonna have like a you
know we'll have to have like a covered
you know like cold and flu covered
a.m and a covered pm yeah and never
forget that you're like no for real
you're like
we gotta treat this [__] like what is
that a tylenol what it was a tylenol pm
or what is it yeah
just any kind of like cold medicine or
something like that i'm trying to find
the
show flyer for that show that we did but
you know it's just like anyway it's just
like that's just a
the low key outside you can find them on
instagram if you're in the la area we're
about to do a show in san diego but like
this is how they uh
you know they mean they've been doing
shows outside and jamie and i did this
show together
yeah yeah here's what it is i feel that
uh
look what i'm what i would saw you i was
very paranoid um and now
look the comedy's come back dude i've
been doing a lot of shows
i just did the show on sunday night man
it was outside i did saturday night
outside so
i'm getting much more comfortable with
the outside
but i have to try and push my boundaries
like we were talking about to see what
i'm comfortable with because you said if
not you're never going to live life
yeah i mean it's strange but i mean it's
strange like
what's happened in this whole year
though in the whole year of like because
the main problem i think we have is that
it's just like a lack of information so
we don't really
understand i couldn't tell you a thing
about covet action like what is it what
is it you know what i mean i don't know
and then like you know we you know then
we're living in a place where it's like
all right so california has decided to
close down and i don't know if it's
closed because of
health or because of optics
you know i'm not sure dude on on like
three weeks ago i did this little
youtube video and i drove all down
melrose and places that
you know that would be popping at
midnight
from the mel from the improv to you know
uh down the street and we get you know
ramen
uh afterwards and and all just those
shops
and it was dark dark yeah man closed
and then like a week later um
[Music]
that pizza place i i forget i think sows
a couple places
were slowly opening up but they were
putting tables outside and then
tons of plastic and it was just these
little sections so
it looked a little better but right then
i see pictures from florida and people
like
yeah you know so it's like you know flip
schultz is down there doing
five shows a night out yeah man going to
the wing stop after so i don't you know
yeah man i i just i just don't know i i
i feel the same way as you i feel like
it's like you know you you just go
you're
you know we have a healthy fear of um
what you know this is we don't want to
get sick
we're out of age we're in our 40s and
you know you know we're like
man i ain't trying to like you know so
we had this healthy fear
and then you go but you want like the
outside world to
represent the same thing as we feel even
though it doesn't seem it does
so when we look at like california we're
here and we're like okay we're closed
down and we're doing all this stuff and
then you look at these other places and
you go man florida's open texas is open
but not open like people are still
wearing masks and people are still you
know they're doing the things they're
supposed to do
and then we see the numbers and we're
kind of like well what's going on like
how come california isn't doing better
than these places you know then you just
go well is it does it have anything to
do with that you know
like well if there's no there's no unity
like
yeah i live in those fields man by the
greek and i see two types of people i
see
people jogging in full-on hazmat suits
on a beautiful day because the weather's
been real nice
yeah yeah and then i'll see hipsters
in the middle of the street and and on
the grassy knolls
and having wine and cheese with no mask
but the mask
as soon as they're done they'll put it
on yeah so doesn't all that add up to
like one big
ball of germs it's gonna float somewhere
what's the truth
that's what i'm saying and so i like
this that's why i say that's why i say
it seems to be for optics other than
anything else
because it's like when you go to a
restaurant and they go listen when
you're standing up
and you leave your table i need you had
to have your mask off i mean on
but so some for some reason like is
there some imaginary bubble around the
table that like
that they're protecting us you know or
or is it just that
this isn't it doesn't work like that
really but you know
it's like to me sometimes i feel like
it's a dog and pony show just
just for the you know like i said just
for optics you know
bro bro take a bite the virus is like
this right
and then you're about to take a bite oh
no no no that's not cool he's eating
he's eating his way here we go you know
what let me float past this table
because it looks like they on a date so
i don't want to
[Laughter]
this looks uh oh man she got a cute dog
yeah yeah yeah speaking only going to
leave her alone but you know it's like
we want to go
he's like listen we want to get back to
it you know it's like even in hollywood
though like you know it seems like
for you know productions kept opening
and closing and
to me i feel like i mean i hate to harp
on it again but to me again it
it feels like optics more than anything
else it's just because we're in such a
liberal place
and then then the twitter mob gets a
hold of it and then people start to like
you're being unsafe and all this stuff
but i kind of feel like productions want
to go
okay the key grip got sick they want to
go okay he's not coming to set
and they're going to keep him away for
14 days but we're going to continue this
ship
you know but but what they do is they go
oh my god somebody in catering got sick
so
we have to shut the whole thing down to
let people know that we're being safe
you know
i don't think they really believe it
like i don't i think it's all [__]
you know they just you know what i mean
totally did you see that lady man that
video had been crying but
listen you and i are in the business
okay i only just started going out
i had a couple of you know zooms
for the big streamers you know like so
projects are going but
they weren't shooting here if i get them
they're gonna be
in europe you know or somewhere far yeah
it's funny oh not even not even just
that you know it's funny you say that
because
it's like people already don't want to
shoot in california anyway
even without the pandemic because of the
taxes and they make things so hard
so like hollywood had such an arrogant
attitude like well you have to do things
here and they're like uh no we don't
we're going to boston we're going to
atlanta we're going to new zealand we're
going to vancouver
and then after a while then they then
california did that thing oh we better
start giving tax breaks
to these productions and then there's
now now
after this they're going to be like bye
because we'll just zoom call you know
table reads we'll zoom call
auditions people can live wherever they
want the writers can live wherever they
want
california is really messing up man they
really messing up so now you cut to
what you're saying now they're just
going to be like yeah we want you to do
this movie and we're going to go do it
in a place that is more reasonable
you know what i mean yeah bro that [__]
well they're shooting a few things in
puerto rico
that's happening and i know i think in
new zealand
and i heard maybe atlanta but like
all of these like you know different
streamer shows that went on i went on
three
they were all in london so that's that
that would be a different one but like
did you see the video of that lady who
had her restaurant shut down
yeah and then you pan over and there's
crew members just chowing down in a tent
and she's like why can't i do the same
thing
yeah i was i did you and i make our
living like this and i still don't i
didn't
i didn't think that was right either let
her be a part of it
or they can't do it it's not fair yeah
it's a crazy thing so it's like so then
you think so then there's like an other
factor so like i said you have your
optics and then the second thing is you
have economics
you know so it's like you know cause her
business doesn't provide enough income
for her community
and uh people at large it's just about
her
so then the government and all these
people they don't care but like
hollywood that represents a lot of money
so it's like all right so then now all
of a sudden health isn't an issue so
then it makes me feel like hell
is health an issue at all or is it as
important as they're trying to make it
seem to be
you know in in you know in the news so
you know i don't know it's just like
you're
strange well yeah but then and then to
add to that like
i think you and i did the same did you
do the orange county show
oh the huntington beach oh yeah oh yeah
and they don't care at all out there i
thought i was in another world they you
know i was like
i couldn't find a mask i went
that was the scariest thing i had done
i've done some other stuff but like i
said with you i put my toe out there
yeah and each time if i come out and i'm
like okay maybe
so that one dude i was like supposed to
be like a few people it was like
400 people spread out on this beach
yeah and they were i mean hitting you
know it was happy hour
everybody was on their dog the people
right yeah this was in
july yeah yeah and i was like
and the lady's like yo just do it just
do it she paid pretty good
yeah so i was like you know i i'm gonna
brave it out and i slowly
did the show and it ended up being great
but that was like
that's right down the road from us dude
and that's a whole other mindset
yeah man so who knows what's going on
i know i know but we'll see it seems to
you know i think that
now that they've got the vaccine out and
there's gonna be another one you know
this other one the emergency
vaccine and then i read today yesterday
too that they have
uh emergency what do you call it
home covet test now so now you can just
go to see you'll be able to go to cvs
and just you know let me see if i got
covet it'd be like a pregnancy test
you know what i mean you know so it's
like so
because you know because you know what
i'm saying is i think for a couple of
years
we're going to be doing things and
they're going to be like oh you need to
bring your covet test
you know or they or they'll have them at
the venue and everybody's going to have
to like you know
okay you're safe you know they're going
to have some kind of it's going to get
easier and then
then they're just going to be like they
don't care anymore that's what's going
to happen
so we're two years away from being like
and then in two years we're going to be
like can you believe that we shut down
everything for this
you know it's going to be like something
like that that's going to be how because
people forget things quick
you know people forget you know what i
mean
people forget quick so i love it when
like a comic i'll go out to an outdoor
show
and i'll be talking to a comic for like
10 minutes and then they'll tell me oh
yeah
i had that [__] in april i beat that
[__] i'm like
you know what i mean so a lot more
people have it than i realized
no no but isn't there a part of you
okay so i was just in arizona and then
like the uh the
one of the girls that went to city
phoenix i went to stand up
stand up live you entered the big one
yeah stand up like well the bigger the
better
why would you want to be a little better
yeah yeah bigger or better
you know so i don't have to be i didn't
i didn't do i didn't do meet and greets
i didn't do none of that stuff i just
went
are they allowing you to a half capacity
or what
man to me it looked like it was just
normal but i think the tables were
spread out but it just looked like it
was fine and they had like plastic up
in between the things and all it was
it's all it was all nonsense i mean i
just think again
it was just for optics you know what i
mean but um
[Music]
so you know so so i saw one of the girls
that works there
i'm standing real close to her and we're
just talking talking talking and she's
like you know and then she says
yeah you know like you know about a
month ago i had it i'm good now
but so anytime you're talking to
somebody and they say that there's a
part of you that wants to like take
eight steps back
you know so you're so you're fighting in
your mind because you're like oh
i don't want to be that guy i just like
you know i almost feel like before you
start a conversation
[__] should say hey i had covet
so yeah so do you so if you want to be
in my bubble just know
i got the antibodies or i'm not whatever
but just to give you a heads up but at
the same time it's like i don't think it
works like that
but there is something in us that makes
us feel like oh i need to take six steps
back because i don't know what's going
on with this person
it's like i don't know how to feel it's
it really is it is
jarring you know what i mean i take
those six steps
i'm like what do you see yeah you still
you still got that fear in you have them
come up with the v card y'all here's my
v
card i mean
yeah but there's still no proof there's
still no proof that that means that
they're not contagious
there's no you know what i mean like we
don't know we don't know anything
concrete about this i know
are you taking the vaccine are you going
to take the vaccine when it comes around
to us
bro you don't want to you can't you
can't is this going on youtube you can't
talk about that
yeah you're scared yeah see you're i
know you you know my answer
you know what's funny i'm not trying to
get your video demonetized
oh my god you're so funny about you i
remember the last time you were on my
podcast
you are so like hypersensitive
to people that are sensitive
let me ask you this here's my answer it
takes about eight years of developing a
vaccine
but let me take that vac that took about
nine months let me jump right in there
okay well how about this then okay the
entire world was affected
i am not surprised that the
whole scientific community of the planet
was working on this look at the things
we've done
in this world i think that
it's not like yeah yeah because it takes
eight years because
those people that work on it they gotta
get paid they get paid by the hour they
got salaries they got jobs
365 days a year so there's no there's no
rush
so it's like there is like they're
taking their time they're coming in home
hey
at 8 am like hey sheila how you doing
let's work on this thing let's do the
experiments
but when the entire planet is being
affected
i don't think it's out of a realm of
possibility that the
entire scientific community got together
and and and they solved it listen i
don't doubt it that's an
amazing point and i'm just gonna say
you take it and then you know let's talk
well my parents have taken it how are
they feeling
well other than my mom's gills she's
good
these guys go the bubbles start blowing
yeah they're they're they're fine man
i'm listen i'm not like that i've taken
every vaccine but i was just you know
you know
no no i get you know you just listen bro
i get it there's a healthy fear
like let me tell you when i was scared
when i read all these articles about how
over 50 percent of medical professionals
don't want to take it
yeah yo i read that and i was like what
you know and then they're just like and
then you but you have to delve into the
details you just see a headline like
that
and then it makes you scary but listen
the vaccines out they gave it to them
the people that are most susceptible to
kovit and now look at the numbers
dramatically dropping
so yeah how are we doing in california
you know i don't even know because i
don't even know if they're releasing
you know the the numbers proper who who
who decides
like who's counting the numbers you know
what i mean
like like i don't know is there some
company that's like we
you know they got one of the clickers
you know and they're going house to
house you got coven
okay you got gopher like i don't know
how it
i actually don't know how it works so
it's like it's a really strange
it's a really strange thing so it's like
we just have to you know we kind of go
with the mob
you know or like or like to collect i
call it like the collective
consciousness you know it's like
let me give you an example it's like
when al gore was popular
he did something that changed the united
states forever and probably the world
he started making going green
it became like a thing that was
important
and then soon after the whole country
made a slight shift
but it was a huge shift because it was
so many people
buying now electric cars talking about
solar panels and
and so now look at the electric car
market right now and look how many
electric cars are on the road look at
all the companies that are doing stuff
i really think that that he really
helped push that forward
that's what's going to be needed for
this how we feel about kovitt
we're going to need somebody like elon
musk or somebody that you know doesn't
seem as crazy you know what i mean
they start pushing people to like we're
going to be fine
it's not as bad anymore but then we're
going to start coming out of the
woodworks you know
and throwing those masks in the air like
graduation caps
you know what i mean so until that until
that happens though i still think we
like a lot of us especially in our age
group have a healthy
fear of the unknown
yeah i mean it's weird i've been to
places with uh
you know i've i've i've worn the double
mask and i've been to places where
people i hate it when people don't stand
on your bubble here's your circle
there's my circle and then there'll be
somebody in between the circle it's like
yo dude that's not your circle
there's your circle so like i do that
[__]
i'm at trader joe's on the circle you
know and
i do feel that i've been in some
situations that are weird
but i feel good so i don't know and i do
try to stay out outside a lot i wish
they had like a list of things
like you know a list of things where
they go
here's how ninety percent of people that
got covet caught it
you know like i wish they had like a so
you could see like a you know it's like
handshaking uh whatever you know open
mouth kissing uh you know
it's like give me something that i know
because i just don't know if it works
the way
you just described it pump when you pump
to get you touch the pump
i have a electric car so i don't have to
deal with that at your house and pump
plug it in yeah yeah so you never use a
public electric
um not any not anymore
you touch your credit card and put it in
yeah okay
you use a napkin no all right
so i'm just wondering what you touch
that's what i'm saying so if you have
like but see some people have that ocd
germaphobia type thing anyway yeah
i don't either i don't i just i just go
i have
a lot i have a sanitizer in my car i
just i try to do that i try not to touch
my face and all that stuff that they say
not to do but
i mean i you know i wash my hands i i
don't go out a lot i go out with a
purpose
you know it's like i'm going here i'm
coming back i don't like being out
because i don't like wearing masks i
just don't like it
what's up guys this is eric griffin i
want to talk to you again about the best
mattress i've ever had in my life
helix sleep the helix sleep mattress
they got this two-minute sleep quiz to
customize the mattress for you
that is the best part about it because
listen you can't go to the mattress
store right now
what you're gonna lay down in somebody's
covet we don't know what's going on
right now we don't know when the world's
gonna be safe
and sleeping is the most important thing
especially when it comes to health and
not being able to sleep right now
because of today's politics because i'm
thinking about pandemic what what's
going on with your love life
just any other drama that you know we
talk about even on my show all those
things that come up in the world
we need to sleep that stuff off sleep it
off all right
and like i said the best part about it
is this helix sleep has this quiz that
you take it's two minutes
and you complete it it it's set up
especially for your body type
if you're big or small if you're a side
sleeper if you're a back sleeper if
you're asleep on your stomach
you need it hard firm you fill out this
whole thing it's just like it's almost
like eharmony for uh
for you and your mattress you know what
i mean it's like a little dating service
and they set you up and
you get the best freaking mattress
you'll ever have now helix is offering
up to 200
off mind blowing 200 off
the mattress and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helixsleep.com
griffin guys get this
damn mattress it'll be the best
mattress you've ever had let's get back
to the show
it makes me uncomfortable yeah okay
but that's just that's just one show you
did
you did the zoom show at the factory
right yeah i did it once yeah
now i felt pretty safe there but i was a
little scared at first but
everybody was real spread out nobody and
it was it was
that was fun that's what i'm saying dude
i feel like you're not there yet
i mean i think your fear level your fear
level
is like you know if if 10 is like
if 10 is like i'm at home in a hazmat
suit and you know
where you before you go out before you
have to depressurize
you have to like depressurize on your
own that kind of thing if it's like
you know i think if 10 is that you're
probably like at a seven
you know what i mean and like everybody
like i think you know say maybe the
average in california is like people are
out of four
you know where are you at you know i
i i'm really i've probably had a two
like i'm probably
you know i've gotten four i've gotten
four covid tests uh
you know my girl works at target you
know what i mean
that's good so you know i had one copa
test and i was good
but here's the deal you're i'm never
like this
oh there's a reason i was going to tell
you it was because
i think i might have actually had it the
only reason i got a little fear-based is
because of the [__] they're saying
but i was so sick over a year ago
like horrific i did a run on the road
and when i
i was in detroit and that was the last
place and i was so
sick i came home for three days
bedridden
and then boom and i haven't been sick
since
like it's crazy knock on wood so
i don't know but it was in december of
and they said it wasn't here but i was
in saudi arabia where you were
i was in italy that summer and i was in
hawaii
three different places that are big
tourist attractions
um i feel like there are certain things
that we should incorporate
that we should keep from this and move
forward with like
i'm not necessarily thinking we should
like wear masks all the time
but i don't mind if people want to wear
masks like if they you know what i mean
but it's like it's like you know we
really have you know taught people about
like hygiene and health and like
keeping a healthy distance and you know
you know washing your hands and all this
kind of stuff i think is going to help
because like when we do because like
when we're on the road i always feel
like comics are like roaches i mean i
think we
i think we're exposed to a lot of things
but at the same time though i think that
scientifically it's also important to
expose yourselves to some germs to have
an immunity to them because if you're
like somebody that wants to live in like
a
a white room in your life all the time i
think you're gonna
though that's the person that's gonna
get the sickest
no you're right dude well i think it was
you that was saying he was like
you know you're f i think you were
saying like yo elbow bump is all right
now
you were always good with the fist bump
anyway you were saying yeah it's like
it's like we're
but like at the same time those like
look i miss that i miss contact i'm a
hugger
you know i like seeing people like you
know especially like after shows man
if you see all the pictures people have
it's like every they like standing right
next to me they like to you know they
want to be all upon you it's like oh man
it's montage from workaholics you know
they want to like be in your space
and so you just go all right this is
like like
how's this going to change us you know
so i don't know man it's uh
[Laughter]
you know i mean it's like i you know
it's like we just kind of go all right
better to be safe than sorry i think
it's a good it's a good mentality like
i'm not one of these people that's like
oh this is [__] we need to just get
out you know what you doing man give me
a hug
you know i'm not like that i'm sad i'm
sad that we're not
more interactive that way but
it is i understand it is what it is
did you yeah did you drive to arizona
fly
i flew and that was spooky at first but
dude you got to read up on this you
should very much read up on this you
know
the planes are the planes are some of
the safest places
i know it seems i know it seems crazy
because you like
listen if you sit next to somebody who's
obviously sick that person shouldn't
even be on the plane anyway
you know like you know because that's
the big pushback it's like well if
somebody's coughing right next to you
well you would think that somebody
that's that sick is not even gonna be on
the plane in the first place that's the
whole idea of like why they go
please you know make sure you're not
having these symptoms and if the you
know
you know what i mean so but like yeah i
i was a little nervous at first too
about the plane
but then i but they say the plane's the
hepa filter was it power yeah
yeah this every plane i was on going in
front it was jam-packed
you know middle seat it was jam-packed
dude they don't care oh
damn yeah they're they're like they they
they've already done their but the thing
is they've done their studies like
united airlines is letting you know they
put it out there they're like
you have zero percent chance you
probably go there you have practically
zero percent chance of
catching this airborne because of the
filters on the plane they're very
they've very much done their study
listen man they got contact tracing for
this too
you don't think that if if somebody
caught covet on an
airplane that would be out that would
that's
that you the way cnn fearmongers on
you know every day they want to show
like this is the youngest person to ever
die of code they
they love making us nervous and scared
you we would know already there's a
south they would have a count
how many people it would be a ticker on
the bottom of cnn talking about these
are the people that have died on
airplanes because of
get catching it on an airplane you know
i i think that
i don't know man but apparently the
airplanes are pretty safe in terms of
like the air
quality and all that stuff so you know
and then they had this whole procedure
okay first five rows can exit
then the next five rows get up you know
they're trying their best to like make
people feel like this is okay
but i was nervous because of the same
reason you're i could
look on your face and see that you're
not gonna fly now because i just said
this
so i no that's my next thing i got to
eventually
i'd rather drive but you know not me not
me
no no thank you i don't know i'm not i'm
not doing that i
i i no man i just don't i don't believe
like even
even with the way it is right now the
numbers didn't
you know 400 000 people is a lot of
people that's a lot of people but when
you delve into the numbers and you see
like what are the age of most of these
people
what are the pre-conditioning conditions
and stuff like that i mean this is not
like dude
it's not like something where like 35
million people are dead and they're in
their most and they're all healthy and
you know it's like all ages and we don't
know what's going on with this if it was
like that this would be a whole
different situation that's not the case
so i've always had like a i've always
had like okay
i don't want to get this but i'm not
living my life in fear
because just the numbers themselves that
they are they're already putting out
it doesn't it doesn't show that you
should act like that
you know what i mean all right i agree i
agree you know what i mean so
so i i got but but at the same time
though i got on the plane
and i was a little bit like but i was
like i wanted to do a tester flight
arizona's only an hour
so this is a perfect you know i wanted
to see how am i gonna feel in this dumb
ass mask
for an hour and and you know and all
that stuff and it was i was fine
it was it was fine i got there you know
when i got to the hotel i was like okay
cool so now i'm in my little bubble
in my hotel room you know i have my own
standard i have my
own like disinfectant wipes if i wanted
to use them i could you know you would
wipe down the remote you wipe down you
know what i'm saying you know that's
just so that's just precautions that we
probably should have done
anyway how nasty people are right you
know
you know how so you know how we don't
like going to like
comedy condos well how are hotel rooms
any different we're just assuming
because they got maid service that is
fine
but you know what i mean like so we're
we getting that blue light
yeah we just exactly we just have to
have our own habits that we're going to
help ourselves be healthy so
you know i i suggest that to you that
you have a little jamie kennedy kit you
know what i mean where it's like
gloves that go to here and you know
yo i want to get that thing
do you have a face shield yeah no i got
i just got the mask
but the face shield i guess that's good
but did you see that helmet with the
like the air flow and all that [__]
yeah man i mean i get it what about the
crowds when you're there like so they're
laughing
yeah there wasn't plastic covering you
though like no no no
and then after they had like they
actually had a they actually had a red
they had to have some tape on the stage
to tell me to stay in this area so i
called it the karen line
[Laughter]
and then no one rolled up to you
afterwards you like no no i didn't even
i didn't even go out i did see some
comics out there like thank you no
no no no no no i i told him i said
listen i said i'll say i said i'm not
doing a meet and greet
thank you for coming though but like i
don't know y'all
smart you know what i mean so it is what
it is you know
these five things yeah
hey what's up guys i'm here to talk to
you about my favorite new sponsor it's
betterhelp.com
that's b-e-t-t-e-r help h-e-l-p dot com
and go to slash griffin betterhelp.com i
want you to start living a happier life
today and as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin guys um therapy is important
i think it's an essential part you know
it's a central part of listen my life i
it really helped me because there's
things that interfere with your
happiness there's things that get in the
way
you know and these people they're
licensed professionals they're going to
help you with depression stress
anxiety whatever issues you might have
lgbt
self-esteem whatever it might be and
it's all from the comfort of your own
home you don't have to have the stigma
of going into an office and dealing with
any of that stuff like that
you connect in a safe and private online
environment
you can communicate in under 48 hours
set up your schedule it's not a crisis
line it's not a self-help it's
professional counseling done
securely online and i highly recommend
it join one million people have taken
charge of their mental health all right
that's betterhelp.com griffin for 10
off your first month i really
want to thank better help for being a
sponsor for griffin with griffin
and you guys take charge of your mental
health let's get back to the show
yeah you know and i it's the first time
i've been out of town in a year
so i i was really i was more nervous
about my set than getting covet
[Laughter]
i mean it's true i'm just being honest
with you you know so i uh
you know by the time but then i got my
sea legs after the first show i was like
oh man
it's like i never left you know what i
mean you know because yeah you know so
i don't know man it's uh we just we just
gotta we just gotta get out there
we just gotta get out there and do it
but i again i understand
from i i just always remember seeing you
and just like you just had
your nervous energy at that show
and i was like okay here there there's a
they go scaredy cat
[__] back of a will say though that
that show is set up dope so it's in that
like open air which is good and
everybody had masks
which was good but then like the mic you
know people are kind of wiping the mic
and i'm like
kinda you bought your own mic didn't you
i brought my own mic and then it didn't
work for like
jared and mike at a u-haul show
with seven other comics i mean dude
that's that's patient zero you know well
they had
they had two mics they were wiping each
back and forth
every show i've first of all i used to
feel that way anyway about like
microphones even when it was just like
sometimes you smell the mikey like
dude you all got to clean this like this
is funky as hell
so like you know now i know i feel like
moving forward
i want to make sure the mic is clean you
know it's like
these are the these are just things we
need to add we're just going to
anyway to do anyway exactly so i don't
think we should look at him as like you
know
make us scared we're just like all right
we should have been doing it like i
tried never stuck with my face
i never you know i'm fine with it but
you but you know it's funny because it's
like
i think that like the like we're
supposed to be in flu season right now
and it's like
we're not it's people are doing great
because
all of these procedures that people are
now implementing like wearing masks and
social distancing and other stuff i
think we're like beating the flu this
year
you know yeah that's that's a little
weird though like yo where'd the flu go
listen it didn't go anywhere it's just
that we are doing things to
because we don't realize how nasty we
really are as human beings and like
the the way we you know spread things
the way it is you know
but it's funny because man people are
out here getting covet tests and worry
about covey with
on some flimsy contact tracing you know
it's like you
you [__] well you know like your ass
would be like man i was at this show and
then i heard somebody talking that that
mailman
might have had kovitz that he got from
delivering something that's
and you're asking run out and get a
covet test
but but i'm still but i'm sure you'll
still raw dog a stranger you made out of
no man i do that joke i say people are
hooking up doing this [__] like some
dude i was
talking too hooked up i'm like yeah he's
like she was cute i'm like yeah but
is she ventilated cute i mean come on
man
that the one you want to possibly go out
on so you just saw you just you just
gonna be like
single
[Laughter]
scared and single that's gonna be the
day of your horror movie
scared and single volume two
[Laughter]
uh yeah oh yeah cause what was that
movie wait yeah that's the one you were
in too right with the mask
what's the mom i forget scream
yeah the new scream is just gonna be no
mass it's gonna be somebody with covey
you know what i mean that's gonna be
there
and then the whole he'll be like it's
gonna be who's spreading it you know it
won't be to the end
that'll be the plot at the end she goes
i spread it because
you did this to me and you did this to
me
you didn't stand in your six foot bubble
that's so
funny dude yeah that's the new horror
monster
it was funny you know you mentioned that
we went to like saudi arabia saudi
arabia that was like
listen i've been to saudi arabia like a
few times
but i've gone when it was like you know
we had to be at an embassy because we
couldn't
you know we couldn't do comedy there and
now this prince
who's like yo i think we need to open we
need to like get with the times
you know and he comes in he's like all
right women you can drive now
you know and then there's music in the
streets and we're gonna have a festival
and we're gonna have people come to
you know people can come do comedy and
all this kind of stuff i mean it was
like
it was strange but it's funny to me that
you're scared of covet
but you flew to saudi arabia
yo you took that flight that flight was
bombed bro it was so
yeah but yeah but you didn't you see
that advisory warning that it was like
you know
there was a lot of reasons to be fearful
of flying to the middle east man
you know what that's where i'm that's
where i'm at on blonde because
you know you just that check was nice
and i'm sure and i'm sure the comedy
club called you like hey we gonna pay
you that money you made from saudi
arabia
your whole covent fear will be like okay
i'm right um
i'll be there yeah yeah
your ass will sit on somebody's lap to
fly there
[Laughter]
yo you texted before i'm like that [__]
you're like yo i'm hoping this [__]
cashes i'm like they play you in the u.s
they're like yeah man they're paying you
they're not paying you in drachma
actually a lot of people didn't get
their money right away
we got lucky but we dude we went i went
over there
i basically slept on the flight three
square meals
it was great cheese crackers yeah yeah
yeah you know
i mean i don't know why then they they
shuttled me right to the radisson had my
sweet
yeah my internet up i was good i don't
know what was the danger
i was good went afterwards took the
falafel
smoked uh some hookah we were all good
listen i didn't even go i didn't even go
out i just i went from the venue to the
hotel back to the venue and none of that
i didn't know venturing
there no man i didn't know the whole
street fair well i didn't do none of
that stuff
i didn't do none of that stuff i was
like no thank you because like because
al madrigal he sent me this like united
states advisory warning about americans
traveling
to saudi arabia in the middle east and
and the dangers and i was like okay
so i had this healthy fear i didn't i
was ignorant
i'm out there yo let me try some of that
falafel
so you out you out at a you out at a
freaking wet market
yo so you see you out here you out here
where kovis starts
talking about i'm good because you had
because you was thinking about that
money in the back of your head
i got this money bro me and lonzo dude
we were out there testing all types of
food
it was great yeah well i mean i i
enjoyed myself i mean
the shows were terrible there was like
11 people in the crowd
you know what i mean and i was like
looking at myself howard how would it i
was like how are they justifying this
money
because guys let me just tell you we
ain't gonna tell you the amount
all right we ain't gonna tell you the
amount but it was a lot of money
it was equivalent i would tell people
that like
that like a good sec college would pay
it was a good amount of money
yeah man yeah dude that's so
funny but i mean they were really
appreciative they'd roll up
yeah like phantom yeah man family would
get out
yeah who do this and you don't
understand but so you don't understand
dude ten years ago
men and women couldn't sit together uh
you know they they
you know i didn't even know that yeah
dude they couldn't have
things like that there was like
religious police out in the streets
you know you couldn't you know there was
so many like ridiculous
like you know archaic freaking
restrictions
and now this new young prince comes in
and he's like you know other than him
killing the
reporter you know what i mean you know
what i mean other than
that he's trying to you know because i
think he wants businesses to come there
he wants like you know
trade and commerce and he's trying to
open up the you know the country because
people
so many people go to beirut they go to
bahrain they go to like all these other
places
and you know and he's like hey come to
saudi arabia too so i mean i don't know
it just was
it was it was strange well people like
how was it doing comedy there i'm like
well you can't talk about sex you can't
talk about politics you can't talk about
religion
and they're like so what'd you do i'm
like not comedy i'm like all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna level up on the
noise game start making them funny
noises
it's funny you say that that's the first
thing i thought to when i heard you were
going i was like what's jamie gonna do
i heard about you and paulie shore i was
like what are
they gonna talk about
[Music]
that's gonna be a nightmare
don't throw out those impressions man
yeah
what the [__] what were you gonna talk
about man
what are you talking about i gotta lie
you don't know me
where you started with the where are you
from oh how you doing sir
we got that it was it was it was a lot
you know i think i think by the time
and then they weren't they didn't know
they didn't care they didn't know how to
promote they didn't even
they weren't even promoting the shows
they weren't they were just like putting
them on because they got money from the
government the government's like
here's like however many you know all
the money they gave them said you know
put on shows
you know then the guys put on the shows
and then and they were like they didn't
even think oh yeah we're not getting
people to come
but again that check was
nice yeah
i felt like i was stealing money that's
what i'm saying
i felt like man they paid me to fly here
that's what it was
they paid that's what i it wasn't even
for the show but i feel like that when i
do college shows anyway i feel like
they're not paying me for the show they
pay me like when i go to do a college
show i go i'm just flying someplace to
pick up a check
because you know and you get to check
and you're like all right it doesn't
even matter what happens here
you know they're just so it's so it's so
such a ridiculous situation
but you have i haven't done colleges in
eight years have you done colleges
recently um
yeah i've done a couple of colleges and
i've even done some virtual years
i've even done virtual shows yeah man i
hate them
i think that they're i think they're i
know why you don't do them because
you're so scared of any kind of
sensitivity issues
no you don't want you don't want the
college being like he said
female with an inflection in his voice
uh and
then that's the end of you but they're
not even booking them as much
like it's less yeah that used to be like
i remember one that's the bread and
butter man dude it was
me it was like the real world cast
and it was ludicrous and it was spring
break and it was
it was on i mean where are those shows
well i'll tell you what i mean the kind
of college show you could do at this
point right now is more like a seminar
than a college show
yeah exactly no for real it's like you
know you just have like
um you know you have a powerpoint
presentation and you just like
so this is the set of the mask and this
is what i was doing there and you know
you tell little funny anecdotes and like
that kind of thing and this is how i
want you this is how i made it
i mean if you put together something
like that you know it's like you know
who does that man
you be surprised like john legend man
john legend
john legend goes to to colleges
he don't even sing
wow but he's like like you got to pay
you got to pay him
extra that's a whole other fee but he'll
go
to talk about the business talk about
music talk about playing the piano talk
about his life whatever like that a lot
of people doing that kind of jimmy
fallon was doing that
i heard just doing a powerpoint
presentation and like so a lot of people
not everybody's doing comedy i'm saying
so it's just something to think about
you know what i mean like you gotta know
you know you're famous enough where it's
like and people
they'll be like oh we want because these
college kids they don't know i did a
college show one time where i didn't
know that
they were doing this they're playing my
comedy
before i come out they're playing like a
you no it's not because i didn't know
they were doing that and i'm coming out
doing the same jokes
oh i hate that they're idiots yeah
usually some some like some like theater
chick
and she's got like and she's in charge
of like 200 grand
and she's her top of her disposal it's
crazy it's incredible
i know i i i would always tell my agent
it was like listen no matter what the
amount is
try i said this i would go like this ask
for as much as you can
but i'ma say yes you know what i mean
yeah
nobody because even because even because
even if it's like you know i know this
is going to sound like a lot of money to
some people but for college gigs it's
not necessarily a lot of money but like
if they go
if they you know you ask for the world
they go we only got five grand
yeah you know you go say yes i mean
because it's because it's one night you
know what i mean
that's what i usually like a cafeteria
show don't just throw yourself
into the cafeteria whatever it what
actually whatever it is who cares you
were going for like one night you know
it's like it's just like a money grab
you know because they got the money
they're like
i remember one time i knew i knew i was
getting underpaid
when the the college said to me we were
so surprised to get you at this rate
i was furious
it really is i mean the only next level
is the corporate like a corporate will
pay you sick money
right man when you do some corporate
show and it's like you don't have to do
you have to do twice it's not even
those kind of shows it's not even comedy
this is a the people that understand
like that's where there's no
i don't know let me say this differently
it's comedy
it's not art no exactly we're not this
isn't for art this is for this is for
money
this is to like you know we're making
sure that these people have as good of
time as they can
we're not ruffling any feathers i'm not
doing my we're not coming here doing our
you know
america i'm white man you know i'm not
doing that stuff and
you know you know what i mean this is
just like uh you know so
airplane food guys right you know it's
like whatever it is because they just
it's just the the company trying to give
back to the workers
you know you know what i mean whatever
that is and then you're just picking up
this check and you're just like wow i
can't believe i made that money to do
that that's what i always say to myself
when i'm done
you're making fun of bill from the
county they're laughing it up
do do a couple of jokes about the vice
president because you know he's a good
sport you know what i mean and then they
just that's it
i've done a few shows like that oh dude
and then you bounce you pick up a fat
check and then you go and you work your
set
out yeah right right right right right
yeah but totally different and by the
way i mean it's like
i i i do miss that to segue into that i
just miss
like i haven't been able to work on
comedy the way i know i need to work on
comedy to be great at comedy
you know comedy is the thing that i have
to be doing consistently i have to
i have to i have to work on the little
nuances of my jokes and
inflections and how i perform it and how
it sounds and and how i'm the pauses and
i can't do that from home man i i
literally hate this and i'm at the point
now man where
i care about that more than i care about
being scared of covet
that's where i'm at i hit your point you
hit your i'm at my exactly i'm at my
point where i'm like all right
let's we got to get back to some sort of
normalcy and this is why i went out on
the road and that's why i'm like okay i
told my agent i'm ready
so take me to all the red states
you know there's people that have been
doing that already for five six months
by the way
but i wasn't one of those people i was
like ooh you know i'm i'm
i'm i'm 40 mom you know what i mean i
can't be
where are you going next um i think i
have
well i have some ones that i already had
booked that they keep moving
so one is like in chicago the den
theater in chicago
and then another i have another one i
think boston
and then there's a couple that i have to
look at my calendar and see like where
they moved them to
so and then i'm ready i'm ready to go to
texas i'm ready to go to florida i'm
ready to go
i just moved my one i had my one in
tampa and i moved out a couple months
and then i'm going to just
go because i think yes yeah
i'll go july and then it'll be
because i want to like work the shows
here and i'm fine just
still getting [__] done i'm kind of this
has been a productive pandemic
listen it's totally okay that you still
you're
you're scared it's fine i'm not scared
i'm just like i don't need to be
inside a club in a state where people
laugh and i see the spittle
you know what i mean there's a healthy i
don't know man i think about
you know how they always get the arizona
show or no
no they don't have to wear masks people
they this is what they say
and if we go right to kerry state did
they have their gun exposed
well i mean i think it's safe i think
it's safer in those states
[Laughter]
you ain't wait listen you ain't you
ain't acting up if you think somebody
could have a gun
like 11. how many times you do and you
think i wanna
who's holding a little luger right here
like you know that's in there
well i don't think about it because you
know how many times have you been like
you know this is what i'm saying about
you like you have this healthy fear
kovit
but do you realize how exposed you are
when you're out on the road by yourself
do you understand
no i asked dude i went to saudi arabia
and i didn't get that warning i was at
the
street market by myself and this is what
i'm trying to say dude like
for me listen i can blend in if listen
if
if i'm in saudi arabia and it goes if
i'm if i'm if you and i are in saudi
arabia together and it goes down trust
me i'm gonna be like i don't
know who is this yeah the white man is
here this is the white man get him
man the first time i went to beirut i'm
walking
down the street with the with the
representative okay just
just like liaison and we're walking she
this is what she says we're walking she
goes well
you know last week this is where there
was a sniper right
you know and i was like [__] why are we
here then
[Laughter]
you i mean i was so like i was like what
are you saying but
at a certain point they're partying
like right after a bombing and they're
like you ain't gonna stop us so it's
like some people just have that
but what i'm saying is like how many
times have you been on a road in some
like town like you know
you're in michigan someplace and i think
to myself i'm actually
i'm on my own you know
it's just me in a hotel room ain't no
security sometimes you had some of these
clubs they don't really have security
they don't care about you
you know there's six people in this
crowd could be like i don't like that
joke you did and i'm gonna meet you in
the parking lot and you're like what are
you gonna do
you know what i mean like you know so
like there's already things to be
fearful of
in our business as it is you know other
than that you know and then on top of
that we gotta worry about you know hey
man i know you're gonna beat me up but
can you keep a six
foot
can y'all come one at a time can you put
your mask on before you hit me
dude i think the scariest thing though
is
is uh that couple that will kind of
linger at the merch table after
and then uh that wife that will kind of
come up on you you know and be extra
friendly and the husband will be like
dude oh yeah man she
she loves comedy yeah well
no no okay see see what you're talking
about right now what i'm saying
wait wait that's best case scenario
you're talking about right there
no because usually because usually it's
like no no because usually it's like
this
usually the girl's drunk
she's all up on you for the picture
taken
and you're looking at the boyfriend like
yo
get your chick
and he's like that's just her no no
that's again
that's the best case scenario i'm
telling you
you keep going to that you see that he's
revealing a lot uh
audience that you know jamie has swung a
few times with a couple that's what he's
saying
no you're looking over there he's
putting that out there couples he's
putting that out there that he's he's
open to
uh i'm telling you never had a boyfriend
looking at you funky because the way the
girl is acting
and i'm like yo man i've also just had
the husband be like
she loves comics it's like that's yeah i
know you said that like four you've said
that like four times now so i feel like
you've
you've you've been you know having sex
with a wife while the husband's on a
chair watching i think that
you know what i'm saying is you talk
about scary scenarios that could be the
scariest one
no to me the scariest one is not where
the husband is supportive the scariest
one is when the husband's not supportive
the scariest one is when you know you're
in this situation where it's like you
know
there's some chicks grabbing your ass
while you're taking a picture
and the husband's over here and you're
just thinking to yourself you know she's
all like you know
if you want to you know whatever they're
saying you're just like hey this is a
awkward situation you don't know you
don't know what's going on with this
couple
you know what i mean like people out
there like you know and then nowadays we
have to think about everything nowadays
we got to think about
you know it's like when you're like i
still hug people like this when i would
take pictures
but it's like you know you got to have
your hands you know it's because because
you hear all these stories you know
people like
hey you caressed my back and you're just
like whoa man dude
it's like whoa you know now you just
want to take all your pictures like this
you know it's like thank you the merch
table dude i do exactly that
i do exactly what you do but also i
don't mind
the drunks not grabbing me anymore
because you know you don't realize that
we get
we're tired we do two shows press all
day
and people just grab and pull you down
i've had people pull me down and club
i'm like
i mean the [__] we could say right i
mean yeah man it's it's
it's crazy like the people well because
they feel ownership i don't know
the entitlement there's a certain
entitlement of like them like if they
paid a ticket so now they're entitled to
treat you however they want if they're
buying your merch if they like
or just that they think that i'm a fan
so therefore i'm entitled to
a b and c and you just kind of like and
you have to try we try our best to be as
gracious as possible but you know
sometimes it's going to slip through not
everyone's going to get the same
treatment because
the sheer numbers of it but for the most
part
you know we're not complaining it's just
like this is just one of those things
that happens
it's just one of those things that
happens man what i'm saying is yeah when
i hear
stories and it's bad you know i feel bad
for everything
i just wish that comic stories were
exposed of how
we get grabbed we get pulled we get i
mean you know
people do treat us like zoo animals
sometimes i'm not complaining i'm just
saying show all of it
right right right right right right yeah
well then and then if you don't say
anything
if you're like yo could you bet ah
story for you like i i'm in new jersey
not new jersey i'm in uh was in new
jersey no no no
i was in connecticut i'm in connecticut
at that one of those like casinos that's
way out like blair witch project
you know it's like far in the woods and
all of a sudden there's a casino
and i'm in a hallway late
dude in a wheelchair and his buddies you
know dude sees me and he's like
oh [__] my chest
you know he's like yo y'all
whoa look at that it's my jazz y'all
he's screaming he's like
you know the one dude pushing the dude
he's like oh look at this man
he's coming he's circling around me as
i'm walking and i say like this
hey man can we just can we not do that
i'm just trying to
go to my room he goes like this you
ain't that famous
you had one tiny request not to get
blown up right there you didn't want
your [__] all blown up you were all
tired
it just i i didn't even want that even
if he didn't know who i was i wouldn't
want him being like
yo dude in a red shirt look at this dude
i wouldn't even want that it had nothing
to do with the fame or anything
it just was like yo dude what are you
doing right and then he looked at me
you ain't that's what people want to do
they want to build you up
and they want to tear you down
they love they love it equally they love
it equally especially right now society
they want to build you up and they want
to tear you down
and they get the same thrill it's the
same endorphin rush it's like
if you see a celebrity that you oh my
god it's jamie kennedy
and then someone else is like there's
that mother jamie kennedy
same energy same feeling same endorphins
and they get the same
thrill and i just like you and then
we're just sitting there like what did i
do
yeah yeah like i said man we
you're not it's a beautiful position to
be in you know
yes but we are you are we are a little
bit of a zoo animal
and i know sometimes the animals you
know
we have issues all right brother
i'm not gonna keep you anymore we did it
um
just to recap make sure you guys watch
last call
right it's coming out in march you can
find it in all the red states
in the theaters go to go to those i
don't care
movie theaters go there or you could i'm
sure it'll be on streaming services
um and i i really actually i'm gonna i
want to watch it just because of how
you're talking about it i like to see
you passionate about things
um yeah man you know what i mean i'm
glad and i'm glad you do you know you
know what i'm glad you're staying busy
i think that you know i hope i hope in a
couple months you're not as
you know scary about scared about stuff
and you get yourself out there
because you know this is what we've been
doing we worked hard our whole lives to
get to a point where we could do these
things and it just got taken away
so hopefully we can like get back to
some sort of them of
normalcy with healthy precautions that's
what i want to see
happen you know but i appreciate you and
thanks for being here thanks buddy
thanks for having me man
appreciate it all right y'all that's uh
our episode uh this week
um you know look for real world advice
from a grown ass man next week maybe
rachel's gonna come back i don't know
what
uh you know this this podcast is ever
changing ever evolving and growing so
uh that was a great time i'm glad my
buddy came on mr jamie kennedy thanks to
him again and remember you can catch me
daily on twitch
and uh guys you know i really appreciate
all the love all the feedback
i do read some of the comments even
though i shouldn't uh you know but it is
what it is because i like to be
interactive with my audience
and so guys thank you for being here
once again
and i will see you next week